more evidence the far left is ready to
hijack a joe biden presidency if he wins
bernie sanders with this message to the
squad
we understand that electing biden is not
the end all it is the beginning
biden's proposals in this campaign are a
lot stronger than they were
in the primary do they go as far as we
would want
no they don't we're not giving up on our
agenda we're going to introduce
medicare for all believe me we are green
new deal we ain't giving up on that
we organize our people to make sure that
biden becomes the most progressive
president since fdr
but not so fast bernie joe biden is
reportedly mulling a plan
to keep all current senators out of his
cabinet meaning
liz warren and sanders would be out of
luck
dana this is kind of a crafty move by a
a presumptive uh president-elect yeah
when i first saw it i was like that's
really smart because it does a couple of
things
one it gives them um a clear line like
here's our red line we're not having any
senator so stop calling
don't have your people call stop putting
it in the hill newspaper stop putting it
on twitter stop having your friends call
us
because we are not going to have any
senators just a moratorium on that
the other thing for elizabeth warren is
she would be up for reelection in 2022
there is a republican governor in
massachusetts if the senate
is going to be held by republicans
barely even no but if the republicans
are going to hold on
then why would they risk having the
governor of massachusetts replace
elizabeth warren
yeah as a with a republican so that she
could be the secretary of the treasury
but that is going to just
give them no end of headaches so i
thought it was super smart yeah greg you
know it would be really smart
the trump campaign just cuts an ad of
that far left zoom call
oh yes and just says this is coming yeah
i was looking at
at bernie with the with the squad it was
like a communist version of charlie's
angels
sanders is charlie's and those are the
angels and every
hour there's like a little plot where
they try to undermine america with
socialist principles
yeah let's tax let's steal all right um
uh by the way just to clarify fracking
and ban fracking uh just to clarify joe
did say there's no way he's gonna put
bernie and liz in a cabinet but he was
thinking about an actual one
oh yeah you have to be clear but bernie
looks at joe
the way dr frankenstein looked at his
monster
he sees it as his creation it's just a
cobbling together of all of these
left-wing body parts
and maybe it'll kind of move down the
into the city
and change things before it collapses
and kamala harris takes over
the biden campaign brett can't be happy
when they see a zoom call like that
these people plotting for how they're
going to influence the new
administration
no as you're making your clothes that
you're going to be the president of all
america
and the progressives are fighting over
what policies they're going to affect
i think the secretary of treasury
elizabeth warren pitch
really was not the best close for the
biden campaign
especially for independents i do think
that attorney general amy klobuchar
could be upset with this decision if in
fact
joe biden becomes president i'm saying
senator klobuchar
being considered but i think that this
is a reminder for people in the middle
or
center left or disaffected republicans
that that is a possibility and the biden
campaign had to stop it
and they had to do something quickly and
they did juan was there anything the
biden campaign could have done to kind
of stop
these people from jockeying for position
so
openly on the eve of this election i
mean they could have waited a week or
two right
no why i don't get it why would you want
to sign it it just doesn't look very
good
socially plotting a makeover of your
administration i must say
i notice you know the stock market today
i know you're very concerned about your
riches
just uh and i understand you market the
stock market went way up and i thought
to myself hmm
i think they factored in the chance that
joe biden might win this election and
they're not
upset about it into they're not upset
about the idea
treasury secretary i'm sorry go right
ahead now go ahead one i don't know why
that's the stock market no because you
guys were saying oh imagine elizabeth
warren in the camp let's say
he said elizabeth warren for treasury
secretary all right you know
would that somehow cause capitalism to
fail would it upset america
answer no answer no answer in fact you
know right now we have a big wall street
guy
as treasury secretary maybe people would
be a working man in america is a little
upset hey they're always looking out for
the rich guy
not for me maybe elizabeth warren would
be a tonic i think that what you got to
understand
is donald trump is not running against
bernie sanders he's not running against
the squad
bernie sanders and the squad in fact are
identified by joe biden as the guy i
beat for the nomination among democratic
voters
maybe that tells you something about who
joe biden is
and i just would say to you look and in
fact at joe biden
he's not for medicare for all right joe
biden is the guy who thinks he's putting
more people
in jail in the 80s and 90s doesn't sound
to me like he's some liberal
good thing oh right oh now it's a good
thing
go vote joke that's what you think you
think it's helpful on the clothes
well i think i think they have a right
to voice just like the
freedom talk is just like the tea party
you're gonna get people who are saying
things
is it helpful in terms of the political
messaging at this point probably
not great but not bad because you want
to make sure that people on the left
are willing to stand in line tomorrow
and vote for joe biden
it may not even be an issue on because
joe might not even win
could be and you don't have to worry
about it